Schönen guten Abend, mein Name ist Ucak. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Analysegespräch durchführen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich Doktor.
Danke. Bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, okay?
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich bin Alfred Han.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Vornachnamen langsam mustibieren?
H-L-F-R-I-D Alfred
Ja?
H-A-H-N Han
Doppel A, ja?
Nein, nein.
Doppel N?
Nein. H-A-H-N
Okay, Han. Herr Han, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 46.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
18.09.1979
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,85 Meter.
Und wie schwer sind Sie zuzeit?
Ich bin 95 Kilogramm, Doktor.
Okay, danke für die Informationen, Herr Han. Was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Beschwerden haben Sie zuzeit?
Doktor, etwa drei Monate fühle ich mich zu einem Atreiblos.
Ich bin total erschöpft und habe keine Lust, Doktor.
Herr Han, haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden früher gehabt?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, Doktor.
Also gibt es einen bestimmten Auslöser für diese Beschwerden, haben Sie bemerkt?
Nein, ich habe weniger Energie als früher.
Ich fühle mich und meine Leistungsfähigkeit hat deutlich nachgelassen.
Okay.
Letzte Woche hat meine Kollegin mich eingeladen.
Es war eine Geburtstag-Party.
Ich habe gegangen, aber ich hatte keine Lust.
Ich habe nicht getanzen oder etwas zu tun.
Herr Han, ich glaube Sie fühlen sich ein bisschen deprimiert seit drei Monaten.
Also darf ich fragen, haben Sie Selbstmordgedanken?
Ja, ich habe keine Ahnung, Doktor.
Haben Sie eine Depression oder?
Herr Han, es ist zu früh etwas genau zu sagen, aber Sie haben ein bisschen Symptome.
Und diese Symptome sind ein bisschen deprimierte Symptome.
Deswegen habe ich diese Frage gestellt.
Ja Doktor, aber ich habe viele andere Beschwerden, Doktor.
Okay. Herr Han, haben Sie noch irgendwelche anderen Beschwerden, Begleitsymptomen bemerkt?
Ja, ich habe viele Symptome.
Zum Beispiel meine Handflaschen sind oft kalt und trocken.
Mein Gesicht wird geschwollen.
Ich vertrage kalte Schlechte als früher.
Mein Herzschlag ist langsamer geworden.
Und ich habe das Gefühl, mich schlechter kontanzieren zu können.
Okay. Herr Han, haben Sie irgendwelche andere hart Veränderungen bemerkt?
Wie zum Beispiel Haar- oder Nägelveränderungen?
Ja Doktor, Sie haben recht.
Ich verliere Haare und meine Fingernagel sind brüchig.
Okay. Und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ja, mein Appetit ist gut.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit unwirkürlich ab- oder zugenommen?
Ja, in den letzten drei Monaten habe ich etwa 4 kg Zugenommen, Doktor.
Okay. Herr Han, leiden Sie unter Heißigkeit?
Ja, ja.
Und haben Sie eine Halsvergrößerung bemerkt?
Können Sie bitte wiederholen? Ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Halsvergrößerung haben Sie bemerkt?
Ja, ich habe nicht bemerkt, Doktor. Nein.
Okay. Ist alles in Ordnung mit dem Stuhlgang? Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang? Wie zum Beispiel Verstopfung oder Duschfall?
Ich habe Verstopfung, ja. Ich habe Verstopfung.
Ich möchte immer ganz lang schlafen, Doktor. Ich bin tagsüber oft schläfrig, ja.
In der Arbeit möchte ich nicht etwas tun, Doktor.
Ich habe Konzentrationprobleme, ja auch.
Ich verstehe Sie sehr gut. Herr Han, also machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Herr Han, aber Sie sind jetzt im Krankenhaus. Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen, hierher zu kommen.
Also wir werden alles für Sie tun, damit Sie wieder gesund werden, okay?
Okay, Doktor. Hoffentlich doch. Aber ich habe viel Angst.
Ja, ich verstehe sehr gut. Aber wie gesagt, machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen. Sie sind bei uns in guten Händen, Herr Han. Ja?
Okay, danke.
Okay, also ist Ihnen übel oder mussten Sie erbrechen?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, Doktor.
Okay, leiden Sie unter Husten oder Luftnot?
Husten, Luftnot, nein.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, ich möchte immer schlafen, Doktor. Ganz schläfrig.
Auch in der Nacht, ja?
Ja, auch in der Nacht und ganz stark, ja.
Okay. Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Ich habe keine Probleme mit Wasserlassen, Doktor.
Okay. Sind Sie schon vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und Covid-Infektionen geimpft?
Ja, ja. Ich habe vollständig geimpft, ja.
Okay. Herr Han, leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit oder Schilddrüsse, Funktionprobleme?
Ja, ich leide seit langem unter einem Schlafabnehsindrom, ja, Doktor.
Seit wann leiden Sie an Schlafabnehsindrom?
Ja, seit 10 Jahren.
Und was nehmen Sie da hin? Benützen Sie eine Maske oder nehmen Sie ein Medikament ein?
Ja, ich war außerdem in SPAP-Therapie.
Okay. Sie benutzen eine Maske regelmäßig, ja?
Ja, ja. Richtig.
Okay.
Vermutlich aufgrund von Nasalpolyphen, Doktor. Ich denke.
Sonst noch etwas?
Ja, außerdem habe ich etwa ein Jahr beidseitige Spannungskopfschmerzen sowie chronische Nackenschmerzen.
Nehmen Sie gegen diese Schmerzen ein Medikament ein?
Ja, ich nehme bei Bedarf Aspirin 15 Milligramm.
500 Milligramm, ja?
Ja, 500 Milligramm.
Und wie oft nehmen Sie ein?
Bei Bedarf einmal täglich oder zweimal.
Okay. Also Herr Hahn, wurde bei Ihnen eine bestimmte Diagnose festgestellt, wie zum Beispiel Migräne oder?
Nein, Doktor. Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich habe meinen Hausarzt gesagt, aber er hat mir gesagt, dass alles in Ordnung ist.
Okay, alles klar.
Herr Hahn, wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin? Darf ich fragen?
Mein Hausarzt ist Herr Schimid.
Okay, ich werde Ihren Hausarzt kontaktieren, okay?
Okay.
Mit diesen Details, ich meine.
Okay, okay.
Sonst noch etwas? Haben Sie irgendwelche anderen Erkrankungen?
Ja, seit vier Jahren habe ich ein Exem auf der Kopfhaut, ja, als das als Szeborajs Dermatitis diagnostiziert wurde.
In welchem Bereich? Am Kopf?
Ja, ganz Kopf.
Okay, überall. Und benutzen Sie dagegen ein Medikament?
Ja, Doktor. Ich benutze Ketazol in Shampoo. Zwei oder dreimal pro Woche.
Okay. Das war es, oder? Herr Hahn?
Ja, das war es.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf irgendwelche anderen Medikamente, außer genannten, ein?
Ja, ich nehme regelmäßig Laktulose-Schrauben gegen Verstopfung, ja.
Okay. Herr Hahn, seit wann leiden Sie unter Verstopfung?
Ich verstehe nicht jetzt. Ungefähr zehn oder zwölf Jahre, ja. Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Okay, alles klar. Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, 2012 wurde ich wegen einer Skapeut Bruch in der rechten Hand operiert.
Hat Sie einen Unfall, oder?
Ja, ja, einen Fahrradunfall.
Ja, sonst noch etwas?
Ja, und 2015 erfolgte ein Eingriff an der Trennensache.
Beidseitig, oder? Welche Seite meinen Sie?
Ja, ja, beidseitig, ja. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was bei mir passiert ist.
Das war eine Operation, richtig?
Ja, das war eine Operation, aber ich habe keine Ahnung.
Okay, alles klar. Noch? Sonst etwas, oder?
Ja, das war es.
Okay. Herr Hahn, sind Sie allergisch gegen irgendwelche Medikamente, Pflanzen oder Nahrungsmittel?
Ja, ich habe eine Allergie gegen Pferdhaare.
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Das reagiert sich durch Hautausschlag und Yukrease in der Nase.
Okay. Und irgendwelche anderen Allergien oder Unfertigkeiten haben Sie?
Ja, auch auf die Klofenak reagiere ich mit einem Eczantem.
Okay. Herr Hahn, rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche seit neun Jahren nicht mehr, aber davor habe ich ca. 20 Zigaretten täglich geraucht.
Wie lange haben Sie geraucht?
Ich habe zehn Jahre geraucht, ja.
Okay, Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung für Ihre Gesundheit getroffen.
Herr Hahn, ich gratuliere Ihnen. Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke täglich ein bis zwei Bier.
Okay. Bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ja, Drogen habe ich nicht konsumiert, Doktor.
Das freut mich. Herr Hahn, leiden Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Schlaganfall, Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja, Doktor, mein Vater hatte eine Nebenniereninsuffizienz.
Okay. Und Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter ist vor sechs Monaten an einem plötzlichen Herzstillstand infolge eines Myokardinfarkts verstorben, Doktor.
Mein Beileid, Herr Hahn.
Danke schön.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe einen Bruder.
Ist er gesund?
Nein, mein Bruder hat einen Kolonkarzinon. Er wurde mit Strahlentherapie behandelt.
Okay. Lebt Ihr Bruder noch?
Ja, ja, lebt er. Er lebt jetzt.
Okay. Und wie wurde Ihr Vater behandelt? Wissen Sie?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, Doktor. Vielleicht vor fünf Jahren, aber ich bin nicht sicher jetzt.
Alles klar. Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe einen Sohn.
Ist er gesund?
Ja, mein Sohn hat eine Gehilfeilbildung und ein Trakostomia.
Es tut mir leid, dass Sie hören.
Danke schön.
Herr Hahn, ja, okay. Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich arbeite vor Verfaltung in einer Viertelstelle.
Sind Sie Angestellter im Verwaltungsamt?
Ja, ja.
Mit wem wohnen Sie?
Ich wohne mit meiner Frau und meinem Sohn.
Okay. Ich bedanke mich, Herr Hahn. Das waren meine Fragen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, Doktor. Ich habe gesagt, ich habe viele Fragen.
Ich habe keine Lust. Ich bin total erschrocken. Ich möchte nicht etwas tun. Was habe ich?
Ich bin nicht Altermann.
Sie haben recht. Herr Hahn, Sie sind jetzt 46 Jahre alt. Aber manchmal kann es passieren.
Aber machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen. Es ist zu früh, etwas genau zu sagen.
Aber ich vermute, dass Sie an Schilddrüssen Funktionprobleme leiden.
Ich möchte Sie zuerst körperlich untersuchen. Dann nehme ich Ihnen Blut ab und veranleite ein paar Untersuchungen.
Sobald alle Ergebnisse da sind, werde ich Ihnen die Informationen mitteilen.
Okay. Danke schön. Bleibe ich im Krankenhaus oder kann ich nach Hause gehen?
Ein paar Stunden müssen Sie sicherlich bei uns bleiben, damit wir die Diagnose bestätigen können.
Aber wenn wir etwas Auffälliges finden, kann es auch passieren, dass Sie ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus bleiben sollen.
Okay, Doktor. Danke schön. Ich warte auf Sie. Danke schön.
Sehr gerne. Bitte nehmen Sie Platz im Wartezimmer. Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Danke schön. Schönen guten Abend Herr Oberarzt. Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen und ich würde gerne über ihn berichten.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich? Ja, bitte. Danke schön.
Herr Alfred Hahn ist 46 Jahre alt, 1,85 Meter groß und 95 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Hahn stand sich heute bei uns wegen seit drei Monaten bestehender chronischer Fatigue, Asthenie und depressiver Verstimmung vor.
Der Patient berichtete über Leistungverminderung, Energielosigkeit und außerdem klagte er über getrockene Haut,
Gesichtodeen, Konzentrationsstörungen, Kälteintoleranz, Radikalie, Olopezie, Onychorexis und Dysphonie.
Als Begleitsymptome nannte er seit drei Monaten eine Gewichtsabnahme von vier Kilogramm innerhalb von drei Monaten.
Er erwähnte, dass er seit zwölf Jahren unter chronischer Observation leidet.
Die regitative Anamnese ist unauffällig. Er sei vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und Covid-Infektionen geimpft.
An Vorerkrankungen nannte er seit zehn Jahren bestehender Obstruktiv Schlafapnesyndrom, seit einem Jahr bestehende Cephalgie und Nackenschmerzen,
seit vier Jahren bestehender Kopfexem, also seborriche Dermatitis, und der Patient nehme Aspirin 500 mg bei Bedarf gegen Cephalgie ein.
Er benutze eine Spapmaske gegen Obststichlafapnesyndrom und er benutze Ketasol-Shampoo zwei bis drei Mal pro Woche.
Er benutze Lactulose-Syrup bei Bedarf gegen Obstpation.
2012 habe er sich eine volle Fraktur beim Fahrradunfall zugezogen rechts, die operativ behandelt worden sei.
2015 wurde bei ihm eine Trennensackenoperation durchgeführt.
Er hatte Allergie gegen Pferdehaare, die sich durch Exanthem und Prythus in der Nase äußert.
Er hatte auch Diclofenac-Allergie, die sich durch Exanthem äußert.
Er sei Ex-Raucher. Davor habe er eine Schachtel Zigaretten täglich zehn Jahre lang geraucht.
Er trinke eins bis zwei Flaschen Bier täglich. Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
In der Familienanamnese gab er an, dass die Mutter vor sechs Monaten an Myokatinfakt verstorben sei.
Der Vater leide an Adrenalinsuffizienz.
Er hatte einen Bruder, der an Kolonkarzinom leide.
Bei ihm wurde eine Radiotherapie durchgeführt.
Der Patient sei verheiratet, habe einen Sohn und der leide an Gehirnfeldbildung.
Er leistet die Fachbegriffe Lys Encephalie und wohnt mit seiner Familie zusammen.
Er sei Angestellter im Verwaltungsamt.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf eine Hypotheriose aus, da der Patient typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Der Patient leidet unter depressiven Symptomen, trockener Haut, Gesicht oder dem Lammin.
Die Symptome sprechen für eine Hypotheriose.
Als Differenzia-Diagnosen kommen, werden die Patienten nicht mehr in die Medizin.
Als Differenzia-Diagnosen kommen Depression und Anämie in Betracht.
Um meine Verdacht-Diagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich zunächst die Vitalparameter überwachen und eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob Haut-Negelveränderungen und Radikale vorhanden sind.
Zusätzlich ist eine Labouruntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnose zu gewährleisten.
Ich würde die Blutbilder von CAP, BSG, TSH, T3, T4, TPO, TG und TSH an die Leberwerte bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich eine Thyroidsynographie durchführen, um die möglichen Pathologien zu erkennen.
Ich würde eine Feinnahdelbiopsie durchführen, um ein Calcinom auszuschließen.
Sollte sich die Verdacht-Diagnose bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Ich würde einen Venösenzugang legen und eine Anmeldung aufnehmen.
Ich würde L-Trioxin verschreiben, um die medikamentäre Therapie des Patienten zu optimieren.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mich mit der Medikamentar-Therapie des Patienten ausführen.
Was beachten Sie im Körper?
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob eine Schilddrüsevergrößerung der Medikamentar-Therapie der Patienten ausführt.
Ich würde auch die möglichen Knoten in der Schilddrüse beachten.
Danach würde ich die Haltveränderungen beobachten.
Diese Symptome sind sehr wichtig bei einer Hypothriose.
Sie haben recht, Herr Oberarzt. Die Anämie kommt auch als Differenzialdiagnose. Deswegen achte ich darauf, ob die Kalorien vorhanden sind.
Was erwarten Sie bei der Laborunterzuchtung?
Ja, also verminderte T3 und T4 Werte und erhöhte TSH-Werte.
Und wir können auch verminderte Hemoglobinwerte feststellen bei einer Anämie.
Wie kann man eine EKG schreiben?
Normalerweise leidet der Patient unter Pradiakardi. Deswegen sollen wir eine EKG schreiben, um die möglichen Herzkrankheiten auszuschließen.
Was erwarten Sie bei der TROY-Synthographie?
Ja, also Kleinerung der Schilddrüse können wir feststellen.
Wir können auch die Hormogenisation bei der Schilddrüse und mögliche Knoten feststellen.
Kalte Knoten oder heiße Knoten.
Können Sie uns die TROY-Synthographie aufklären?
Ja, gerne. Ich werde Sie über die TROY-Synthographie aufklären.
TROY-Synthographie ist eine radioaktive Untersuchung.
Diese Untersuchung hilft uns die Schilddrüsefunktionen oder besonders Knochenmetastasen genau zu erkennen.
Bei dieser Untersuchung verabreichen wir eine Schwäche und eine geringe radioaktive Mitteltechnosium 99.
Dann warten wir etwa 20 Minuten bis diese radioaktiven Stoffe in die Schilddrüse gekommen sind.
Danach machen wir Fotos mit einer Gammekamera.
Dabei können wir die kalten oder heißen Knoten genau feststellen.
Nach der Untersuchung soll der Patient viel Wasser trinken um die radioaktiven Stoffe schnell auszuscheiden.
Dafür benötigt der Patient keine spezielle Vorbereitung.
Nur soll der Patient sechs Stunden vor der Untersuchung nüchtern sein.
Nach der Untersuchung gibt es keine Anschränkungen und der Patient kann nach Hause gehen.
Würden Sie in diesem Fall eine Patsy durchführen?
Wenn es eine kalte Knoten gibt und nach einer Fein-Nadel-Biopsie, wenn wir ein Thyroid-Kazinom diagnostizieren,
dann können wir eine Patsy durchführen um die mögliche Metastase genau zu beurteilen.
Würden Sie in diesem Fall eine Patsy durchführen?
Eine Patsy können wir durchführen um die möglichen Befunde im Mediastinum genau zu beurteilen.
Welche möglichen Befunde?
Das ist ein Hypothriose-Fall. Normalerweise warten wir auf eine vergrößerte Schilddrüse.
Normalerweise warten wir auf ein Hypothriose-Fall.
Also eine retroshtanale Vergrößerte Schilddrüse. Aber dieser Fall ist ein Hypothriose-Fall.
Würden Sie in diesem Fall eine Bein-Untersuchung durchführen?
Auf jeden Fall sollen wir eine Bein-Untersuchung durchführen.
Ich habe schon diese Frage nicht gestellt, aber das ist sehr wichtig bei einem Hypothriose-Fall.
Auf jeden Fall sollen wir diese Frage stellen.
Welche Krankheiten verursacht eine Bein-Udeme?
Bei der Herzinsuffizienz können wir eine Bein-Udeme feststellen.
Bei der TvT können wir auch eine Bein-Udeme verursachen.
Auch RZP-L kann eine Bein-Udeme verursachen.
Und ein Hypothriose-Fall kann auch eine Bein-Udeme verursachen.
Auch Nierenwinseffizienz.
Nierenwinseffizienz, ja, Sie haben recht.
Würden Sie in diesem Fall eine Eschokardiografie machen?
Der Patient leidet unter Bradycardi.
Wir können eine Eschokardiografie durchführen, um die möglichen Herzkrankheiten auszuschließen.
Das kann sinnvoll sein, um eine Eschokardiografie durchzuführen.
Was würden Sie bei dem Patienten verschreiben?
Ich würde Ertrioxin als Medikament für die Therapie verschreiben.
Der Patient soll dieses Medikament regelmäßig einnehmen.
Das ist sehr wichtig bei den Patienten.
Okay, Herr Kollege, bitte gehen Sie auf unseren Info-Disc und nehmen Sie Ihr Zertifikat.
Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg und viel Arbeitsweg.
Vielen Dank, Herr Oberst, sehr nett. Danke für diese schöne neue Information.